[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to discuss
the power levels or combat classes of
all seven deadly sins we're going to go
over all the power levels that we got
and for fun try to figure out how strong
each sin is now right up to the most
current events in the manga make sure to
LIKE and subscribe for more seven deadly
sins content if that ain't enough seven
deadly sins for you you can also follow
our instagram at anime up roar for daily
seven deadly sins posts and
conversations keep in mind there will be
manga spoilers in this video you've been
warned
just a heads up if you didn't know I did
a video over three months ago about all
power levels ever mentioned in the seven
deadly sins ranked from weakest to
strongest that was quite a big project
because I included every single power
level we got make sure to check it out
if you're curious about that here I will
take a closer look at the sins
specifically and speculate more about
their power levels even when we don't
have that information I will however
make sure to let you guys know when the
power level is official and when I'm
speculating based on the evidence I will
also incorporate some of your feedback
from the previous video where some of
you suggested putting the actual power
level on screen rather than just saying
it so thank you for the suggestion and
now let's jump into some power levels go
Thurs first recording power level is
3100 however once he regains his
memories his power level shoots up all
the way to 30 5400 power level wise he
is the weakest sin overall but with
abilities like invasion at his disposal
he proves to be indispensable to the
team without his invasion ability
meliodas might have given in to despair
and been defeated by his father the
demon king
so Coulter's character does a good job
of illustrating that it's definitely not
all about power levels deeanne's first
recorded power level is three thousand
two hundred and fifty after she
undergoes droll and gloxinia special
training her resting power level rises
to eight thousand furthermore she can
increase her power dramatically by using
drills dance
in her weaker human-sized form she is
able to use the dance to reach a power
level of 15100 and she lets go tour know
that she can increase it even more
according to the character guidebook in
her giant form she can use drawls dance
to increase her power level to 50,000
thus she has yet to pass drool who has a
parallel 54,000 and become the strongest
giant in history but nevertheless she
has definitely come a long way since the
beginning of the series
Merlin's first and only recorded power
level is 4710 but this doesn't do her
justice at all even at the beginning she
had the highest power level of the sins
not counting her worshipper Eska nor who
was introduced later on in the series
since then she's proven that she can
handle much stronger opponents like grey
road who had a combat class of 39
thousand and a tricky commandant to her
most impressive performance came against
Chandler and Cusack two of the strongest
demons in history and the teachers of
Melly Otis and Zell drous Cusack had a
power level of one hundred and
sixty-eight thousand and Chandler had a
power level of one hundred seventy three
thousand and yet Merlin was able to
overpower both of them until the
memories of mild being Esther Ossa
returned and distracted her considering
this Merlin should be considered to have
a power level of at least two hundred
thousand-plus
however then the original demon comes
along who if he has the combined power
level of Cusack and Chandler would have
a power level of 341,000 against him
Merlin admits that she has no chance of
winning so for that reason it is likely
that her power level does not enter the
three hundred thousands Eska nor power
level is the weakest of all the seven
deadly sins during midnight when he only
has a power level of 15 half the power
level of Hawke during the great fight
festival go thir makes Eskin or think of
Merlin during the night time and he
transforms saying that Merlin is the
very son itself his power rises to
twenty eight thousand eight hundred with
no son and he didn't even need his
divine axe to transform a very
interesting moment indeed
it proves that some power isn't
absolutely necessary for a
transformation during his introductory
fight against Galan Merlin measures Eska
Knorr power level to be around 50,000
but she mentions that it keeps
increasing with every passing moment
then there's the epic fight between
Mellie Otis and Eskin or during this
fight s Kannur is measured at a power
level of 114,000 while noon is
approaching despite the high power level
Mellie Otis an assault mul continues to
easily overpower him until high noon
however during high noon for one minute
s kannur enters the 1 mode and beat
smelly Otis who at this point has a
power level of 140 mm he doesn't just
beat him though he crushes him belly
Otis gives him 1,000 divine slashes and
s kannur brushes them off saying all
1,000 slashes are but an itch
then he beats belly Otis with one swipe
of his hand we are not given a power
level for Eskin or in the 1 mode but I'd
speculate that was 300,000 plus it's
clear that it's way above assault mode
Mellie Otis + he is able to stop self
justice move ominous nebula I moved that
Ludo shel who had a power level of 200
1000 was completely powerless against
yet he doesn't seem to be as strong as
mile with sunshine whose proximity alone
is able to melt Childress's sword the
same sword that blocked the ones karate
chop I speculate that mile has a 400,000
plus power level because of how easily
he beat the original demon who if we
simply add the parallels of Kusaka and
Chandler as mentioned would have a
parallel of 341,000 so in my view s
Kanoa ranges all the way from a power
level of 15 during midnight to a power
level of over 300,000 during high noon
Kings first recorded power level is 4190
he starts out ahead of Mellie Otis ba
and goal Turan Deann when he has to
fight the AL Beyond who all have a
combat class of 5,500 King manages to
defeat him as lark Sania points out
Kings power level temporarily almost
doubled that of the AL Beyond meaning
that King reached a combat class of
around 11,000 during the fight after he
undergoes gloxinia and rolls training
his power level shoots up to 40 1600
however his molé
impressive transformation comes later
when his full-grown wings come in King
Deanne and Gotha were taking on Maya who
had absorbed four commandments and whose
power level was over two hundred
thousand at the time they were no match
for him even a triple combo move was
easily stopped by him however after the
fairy King transforms into the king of
rock mode he takes out miele
effortlessly without breaking a sweat
he's able to fight the original demon
with there's at least three hundred
forty-one thousand combat class from an
extremely long distance King is not even
close to full power because he never
fought from a distance before he can
only use one sacred treasure at a time
from a distance and fighting from a
distance uses up a lot of magic rapidly
nevertheless he's not only able to keep
up with the original demon he's able to
do so well that zelgius feels the need
to step in suggesting that Kings moves
sunflower could have done serious even
deadly damage to the original demon
considering all these factors like that
King was able to do so well against the
original demon with only a portion of
his power
I'd speculate that King is currently at
a power level over 400,000 bonds first
recorded power level is three thousand
two hundred and twenty he starts with
one of the lowest power levels but ends
up becoming one of the strongest sins
when he fought meliodas to bring Alain
back Luther said love caused bonds power
level to grow by 650 placing him at
three thousand eight hundred and seventy
during this battle during the fighting
against Galan bond uses hunter fest to
seemingly absorb more than half of
glands power and some power from the
surrounding area as well add it to his
own he should have an overall power
level over fifteen thousand at this
point however that appears to be his
limit since he can only maintain that
power level for a while before his body
has to deal with the consequences of
absorbing so much power absorbing this
kind of power leaves him unable to move
for an extended period of time after he
comes back from purgatory though he gets
a huge power boost albeit they weren't
at full strength but my land King could
do nothing to the demon king after he
took over Mele Otis's body however bond
as the characters noticed was able to go
blow-for-blow with him he did have
Mellie Otis helping
from the inside which means the demon
king could not have fought bon at full
strength but bond still did surprisingly
well in a fight against a demon God for
this reason I put bond after purgatory
at at least a power level over 500,000
Mele Otis's first recorded power level
is three thousand three hundred and
seventy when he's fighting against bond
go thir says that love causes his power
level to rise by four hundred and thirty
which would place him at 3800 at that
point with his demon mark showing his
power level jumps up to four thousand
four hundred during his fight against
Cal and then he enters berserk mode
which raises his power level to ten
thousand three hundred later we figure
out that the majority of Mele Otis's
power was sealed away and when he gets
reunited with that power his base power
level shoots up to thirty two thousand
five hundred when he comes back to life
after Estero so temporarily kills him
Mele Otis has a base power level of
sixty thousand which becomes even
greater in his demon form he is able to
effortlessly defeat fraud Hrant at this
point who has a power level of thirty
one thousand during his epic battle
against Eska normally Otis is in assault
mode and his power level is 140 mm
mulaskey low suggests that this is how
strong Mele Otis was when he was the
commander of the ten commandments so
from here on out
he becomes even stronger than he was
three thousand years ago but the
question is how much stronger does he
become seemingly no one else could
overpower the demon king bond could hold
his own but he couldn't really overpower
him until Mele Otis beat him on the
inside
Mele Otis though took off the demon
King's arm in purgatory like it was
nothing and then clearly overpowered him
inside his own body his power made the
demon king look helpless he then goes on
to break the curse that was placed on
him and Elizabeth which one could only
do if he had power equal or greater than
the demon king and supreme deity so it
definitely looks like Mele Otis has
surpassed his father in power for these
reasons Mele Otis has to be placed above
bond in terms of strength
so if bond is five hundred thousand-plus
malleolus should at least be placed at
six hundred thousand-plus
now keep in mind I'm speculating about
power level
because I know a lot of you enjoy that
however without knockabout giving us
official power levels we cannot know for
sure the highest specific power level we
gobbles looter shells who had a power
level of 200 1000 at the time and that
was a while ago so we could potentially
even be in the millions by now however
whatever his power level is we can all
agree on the fact that Mellie Otis is
ridiculously Opie at this point and that
is it for today's video thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed the
video make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you have it be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell so you know the second
a new seven deadly sins video is out for
daily seven deadly sins content and
conversations make sure to follow us on
instagram at anime uproar shout out to
our patrons especially to our pro tier
patrons keelon and the one and only
gilgamesh and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans mayan
Gobin Maddie Mac 239 and a 17 FF DP
thanks so much for your ongoing support
if you get value from the stuff we do
consider supporting us for as little as
a dollar month over on our patreon if
you become a patron your name will
appear in future videos along with these
amazing people right here and you'll get
access to our patron only discord and if
you're interested in rockin seven deadly
sins inspired merch you won't find
anything better than anime upper calm we
are selling original and epic shirts
like esken or praise the Sun Mele
Otisfield the wrath Demon King all
hailed the king and of course Sun of
wrath our newest edition so be sure to
check them out at anime AFRICOM there's
more to come including a bond shirt so
look forward to that thanks again and
until next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]